developer gearbox is taking a bit of a
detour from the exploits of borderlands
vault hunters with its next game tiny
tina's wonderlands inspired by the
dungeons and dragons influenced tiny
tina's assault on dragon keep
wonderlands is aimed at bringing a more
tabletop rpg-like experience to
borderlands loot shooter formula
wonderland sees you dive into tiny
tina's latest bunkers and badasses
campaign instead of playing as one of
four pre-made characters a hallmark of
the borderlands series you can pick from
one of six classes and then customize
your race physical appearance voice and
personality tina then narrates your
adventure as you explore her fantasy
world making adjustments to the story
and your quest on the fly much like a
dungeon master and a dungeons dragons
campaign
i've now had a chance to play
wonderlands jumping into a preview build
of the game that saw me able to try out
the stablemancer and graveborn classes i
went for the latter first for no reason
other than that the name sounds cooler
before replaying the first 15 minutes or
so of the preview with the former
between the two i ultimately ended up
enjoying the critical hit focus
stabomancer which plays a lot like a d d
rogue more than the powerful but risky
graveborn which much like dnd's blood
hunter can sacrifice health to pull off
powerful attacks both classes felt
distinct in what they brought to combat
which leaves me wanting to see how the
other four classes berserker clawbringer
spellshot and spore warden might play
differently i also found plenty of loot
much of which felt like your typical
collection of colorful firearms found in
a fantasy based shooter but there were a
few gems that offered playfully silly
considerations to combat the more i
played however the more i noticed that
wonderlands felt remarkably similar to
borderlands 3 a little too similar if
gearbox told me that wonderland started
out as a post-launch expansion for
borderlands 3 before transforming into
its own stand-alone game i wouldn't be
surprised the two games feel as tonally
and mechanically similar to each other
as dragon keep did to borderlands 2. it
leaves wonderlands feeling like a game
i've already played before sure the
exact details of the story are different
but i'm going through the same motions i
did back in 2019 including quests that
feel like reused borderlands 3
fuse the storylines
it ultimately resulted in a boring hour
and a half preview especially for me
someone who has already poured over 30
hours into borderlands 3 and felt like i
was just getting more of that the
preview saw me mostly aiding jar a
goblin seeking to unionize her fellow
goblins in an effort to overthrow their
greedy corporate overseer jar isn't much
of a fighter so she needs you to clear
out any of the evil goblins in order to
save the good goblins and unite them
under her banner a task that sees you
exploring several tunnels and fighting
through a handful of labor camps before
ultimately going up against a
traditional borderlands boss if the
missions are any indication of how
wonderlands will play as a whole they're
not doing it any favors the missions i
played through feel like just another go
at borderland 3 is the guns of reliance
a series of missions in which you aid a
rebel leader and freeing captives and
starting resistance even concluding with
the fight against an enemy that's only
tough because he has a large health pool
in terms of what you're doing
gameplay-wise they feel
indistinguishable the actual storyline
of the quest isn't all that interesting
either as it mostly retreads narrative
ground that gearbox has done before and
better and lacks the playful
occasionally even intriguingly satirical
exploration of concepts and pop culture
that define the best aspects of the
borderlands games an argument could be
made that jar is this aspect an example
of how goblins are everyday people and
not to be generalized as the mindless
grotesque monsters that fantasy and most
d d campaigns make them out to be but
that feels like a stretch especially
given that jar has very little
characterization and even without that
stretch characters in recent popular
dungeons and dragons campaigns like
critical role campaign twos not the
brave and dimension 20 fantasy high's
risk gut-gak have already deconstructed
goblin stereotypes by portraying them as
individuals so as cool as it is to be
revisiting tiny tina's depraved and
silly mind through the lens of a
tabletop rpg wonderlands doesn't
actually seem to do anything interesting
with that lens granted the set dressing
is there the names of mechanics and
features have changed to emulate dnd
killing an enemy to get back up and
prevent your untimely demise is now a
successful death saving throw for
example and grenades have been replaced
with magic spells but if what i played
is any indication borderlands mechanics
haven't evolved to match these new
tabletop terms gearbox has successfully
copied the lingo but i saw no indication
that the team knows what that jargon is
supposed to invoke looking back at the
death row mechanic as an example it
works exactly like borderlands second
wind and wonderlands when you lose all
your health your character falls to
their knees then of a brief period of
time before you fully bleed out and die
if you can manage to kill an enemy
before that happens you get back up with
all your help it's simple to understand
and fairly easy to succeed at so it
doesn't match the joyful exuberance tied
to getting a successful death saving
throw in d in d d successful death
saving throws means your character can
be revived failing your throws means the
character is fully dead and gone for
good beyond a dungeon master pulling
some shenanigans rolling saving throws
is a harrowing experience that can
change the course of a campaign forever
and wonderlands lacks that same tension
because your character's death is
meaningless like borderlands wonderlands
allows you to be revived from a
checkpoint a seemingly infinite number
of times without consequence aside from
losing a small amount of money but i'm
not saying that wonderlands needed to be
a roguelike or incorporate some
semblance of permadeath into its
structure you don't need actual
permanent character death in order to
have a true dnd campaign but this is one
of several examples of how wonderland's
misses the mark and pretends to be
something it's not the game has included
the words but without their meaning
resulting in experience that feels
hollow to its source material so even if
it looks different from borderlands 3 in
actuality it doesn't feel any different
you could argue that dragon keep is
similar that's built upon the mechanics
and gameplay loop of borderlands 2. but
to dragon keeps credit there is
substance to its narrative the expansion
builds upon borderland 2's story making
space for tina to grieve for roland and
that is something that dnd is known for
plenty of folks have explored their
emotions found new friends come to an
understanding of their gender and
sexuality or simply grown as a person
through playing the game so gearbox
using a tabletop rpg to explore grief
and dragon keep was incredible and
clever like of course tina someone who
struggles with expressing her emotions
beyond over-the-top excitement and
explosive outbursts would only finally
be able to explore something like the
loss of her surrogate father through the
act of role-playing in a tabletop game
i'm not getting anything like that from
what i've played of wonderlands though
gearbox has seemingly taken no strides
in exploring how the mechanics and
language of a tabletop rbg could
transform a loot shooter both in terms
of how it plays and what kind of story
it might be able to tell and is instead
seemingly just giving us another
borderland styled loot shooter i can't
judge a presumably multi-hour game on a
small snippet nor do i want to however
the piece of wonderlands i got to play
did not leave me impressed or eager to
try more in a timeline where
wonderland's this borderlands 3 dlc i
might have been more excited the
prospect of a fantastical bite-sized
snack is more appealing than gorging
myself on a whole second course that
matches the first and with all that said
in the game's defense i didn't get a
chance to experience most of the actual
dungeons and dragons concepts that
gearbox has talked about introducing
into the borderlands formula in
wonderland concepts like the table top
looking overworld character creation and
multiclassing and tina adjusting
situations on the fly in interesting or
humorous ways as a dungeon master none
of that was available in the preview
build i got to play but from what i was
able to play i got the sense that
wonderlands is just more borderlands 3
in terms of its gameplay mechanics
narrative tone and quest structure which
i guess is fine if more borderlands 3 is
what you were hoping for but i find that
to be pretty disappointing plenty of
other games are scheduled to launch in
the coming weeks alongside tiny tina's
wonderlands so be sure to subscribe to
gamespot to stay up to date on what
we're playing if you want to see more
preview videos like this one leave us a
like and let us know in the comments oh
not this again
curse these good looks
do i look like i smash
i'm an evil wizard i do not smash